aucune réaction des avocats des prévenus
à la sortie de l'audience
deux mois après le procès de l' affaire
dite des écoutes
nicolas sarkozy est reconnu coupable de
corruption et de trafic d'influencé par
le tribunal judiciaire de paris
l'ancien chef de l'état condamné à trois
ans de prison dont un an ferme
c'est une première sous la vème
république à droite c'est le choc pour
le sénateur philippe dominati cette
condamnation est trop sévère
il dénonce un procès politique le mur
dès qu'on est encore une réalité c'est à
dire que on a du mal à comprendre
parfois quand est ce qu'il y à la
justice et quand est-ce qu'il ya la
justice politique les exemples sont
nombreux de voir que des magistrats ont
largement dépassé le cadre de la sphère
qui devait achever pour simplement faire
du militantisme politique
thierry herzog et gilbert azibert ont
également été condamnés et font appel du
jugement
la peine de prison pourra être aménagée
avec une surveillance électronique à
domicile
l' affaire remonte à 2014 alors que
nicolas sarkozy est placé sur écoute
dans l' enquête sur un possible
financement libyen de sa campagne la
justice débusque une autre affaire avec
une ligne téléphonique secrète sous le
nom de paul bismuth
nicolas sarkozy parle avec son avocat
thierry herzog
une dizaine de leurs conversations été
retranscrite
elle prouve selon l'accusation que un
pacte de corruption a été conclu entre
l'ancien chef de l'état son avocat et
l'ancien haut magistrat gilbert azibert
nicolas sarkozy devra retourner à la
barre le 17 mars dans le cadre de la
sphère bygmalion il sera jugé cette fois
pour le financement dit illégal de sa
campagne de 2012 avec nous pour le match
des idées ce soir thierry fabre
bienvenue rédacteur en chef à challenge
et etienne etienne gérard bienvenue à
vous également chef du service société à
l'express merci infiniment à tous les
deux une dernière réaction sur cette
affaire sarkozy celle de gérald darmanin
il a en ce moment difficile tout mon
soutien amical
alors on n'est pas évidemment dans la
tonalité de la famille
wat qui crie à l'acharnement judiciaire
mais on est dans une forme de soutien là
quand même thierry fabre oui soutien
amical on connaît les liens des deux
hommes donc c'est vrai que nicolas
sarkozy pour gérald darmanin c'est un
peu un mentor donc c'est normal qu'ils
adressent on soutient macal de risques
majeurs et voilà après il faut très vite
dans cette affaire-là revenir au fond et
se demander pourquoi les juges ont été
aussi sévère pour vous ils ont été
abaissés une sévérité pour la
délinquance en ce qu'on appelle la
délinquance en col blanc puisque là on
parle de pacte de corruption donc c'est
la délinquance en col blanc oui de la
prison ferme c'est sévère et je
regardais avant de venir justement les
différentes condamnations dans
différents types d'affaires de notamment
de les affaires de fraude fiscale ou
corruption
depuis ces dernières années il ya une
extrême sévérité des juges on se
rappelle ce qui s'est passé avec
monsieur balkany quand il a été condamné
c'est de la fraude fiscale mais il a
fait de la prison ferme là depuis pour
raisons de santé
il en est sorti mais je vois là elle
s'est alors on peut se dire c'est grave
ce qu'a fait ce que peut avoir fait
monsieur sarkozy c'est-à-dire de 7,7
essayez d'avoir accès à un dossier
judiciaire et en échange d' offrir un
poste prestigieux à un magistrat c'est
ce qu'on appelle un pacte de corruption
mais précédemment c'était pas condamner
à ce niveau là là la prison ferme le
parquet avait demandé plus fort qu'à 30
ou là ils donnent trois ans c'est c'est
le signe que la justice française a
changé ces dernières années
en fait depuis la sphère cahuzac depuis
la sphère cahuzac a eu de nouvelles
institutions la haute autorité
transparence de la vie publique est une
des juges qui désormais sanctionne et
n'hésite pas à envoyer des politiques en
prison alors qu'auparavant ce genre
d'affaires était pouvait être sanctionné
mais beaucoup moins aussi pour répondre
d'ailleurs à une demande de l'opinion
qui demande que la justice soit faite
pour tout le monde
ah mais totalement c'est ce que je
trouve d'ailleurs le plus intéressant
dans cette décision de justice
on sent bien que le juge s'adapte aux
attentes de la société française et aux
évolutions de la société frey est un
juge à l'ecoute finalement de ce que lui
dit l'opinion de là c'est ce qu'a dit en
tout cas le
le procureur de la république dans son
dans son réquisitoire aux qui lui qu' il
était inaccessible inacceptable qu'un
président de la république parce qu'il a
été président de la république et qui
garde en lui un bout de notre institut
de nos institutions et de l'âme de notre
nation qu'ils se rendent coupables de ce
délit de ce pacte de corruption de cette
tentative de corruption à l'égard d'un
haut fonctionnaire du ministre du
ministère de la justice attention tout
de même à l'effet de balancier il
faudrait pas que nicolas sarkozy paye
plus pour ceux qui n'ont pas été
condamnées avant il ya peut-être cette
question qui peut se poser parce que
toute la droite mais dit on crie à
l'acharnement judiciaire yens et parle
de décision politique
oui alors ça c'est la ligne de défense
de la de la droite et de nicolas sarkozy
l'acharnement
alors on peut poser légitimement la
question mais il empêche que vous savez
il ya une certain nombre d'affaires là
cette affaire là n'est pas la seule
bientôt va s'ouvrir le 17 mars la sphère
bygmalion a justement où ils risquent
aussi de la prison ferme priem de siens
voilà quatrièmes dossier il ya aussi la
sphère du financement libyen il ya aussi
la faire des sondages de l'elysée
une sortie par la cour des comptes où
justement baudet des millions d'euros
ont été dépensés sur des sondages
personnel pour nicolas sarkozy et non
pas des sondages généraux pour la pour
la présidence
donc si vous voulez il ya peut-être
certaines affaires on peut peut-être
qualifié d'acharnement aux qu'il a
obtenu un non-lieu et ça a été le cas
dans l'affairé bettencourt mais ça fait
beaucoup de dossiers et on peut
difficilement croire à l'acharnement
systématique des juges envers monsieur
sarkozy quand même des pratiques qui ont
été révélés et qui tranchent avec ceux
qui lui ont succédé
parce que depuis nicolas sarkozy que ce
soit françois hollande au emmanuel
macron jusqu alors en tout cas il n'y a
pas eu ce genre de dérive judiciaire et
du coup je pense que des pratiques en
changer un exemple les sondages de
l'elysée
depuis cette affaire la plus de sondages
nicolas françois hollande n'est arrêté
emmanuel macron les a arrêtés chaque
année la cour des comptes vient vérifier
et donc effectivement on peut se dire il
a payé mais simplement à l'épaule et les
juges considèrent que c'est grave et
l'impact c'est que ce genre de pratique
tend quand même à disparaître dans
certains domaines c'était cétacés
je pense est assez positif à la faute la
justice soit plus sévère que la france
remonte dans les standards
internationaux par rapport à la
délinquance en col blanc et que du coup
on puisse espérer que les pratiques de
nos hommes politiques changent
je vous parlais des réactions sa famille
politique juste une réaction ici au
sénat du patron du groupe lr bruno
retailleau une condamnation extrêmement
dur dans un dossier particulièrement
faible dit il
petit rappel il y a un droit à la
présomption d'innocence tant que les
voies de recours n'ont pas été purgés et
une dernière réaction celle de christian
jacob que vous avez probablement vu
patron dlr soutien indéfectible à
nicolas sarkozy la sévérité de la peine
retenue et absolument disproportionnée
est révélatrice de l'acharnement
judiciaire d'une institution déjà très
contesté et là il parle du pmf toute la
lumière devra être faite sur les
méthodes et l'indépendance du pmf dents
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas été condamné pour le
bénéfice qu'il a retirés des faits parce
que le bénéfice il est nul il n'a pas
réussi finalement à obtenir
l'information des cibles à la tentative
exactement c'est pour l'intention et
l'intention elle est à la hauteur de ce
que
n'importe qui la nation finalement et
attendait d'un président de l'ancien
président de la république
on attendait tout sauf une tentative de
corruption dans un dossier judiciaire à
l'acharnement
je veux bien mais on oublie quand même
que il a le droit à un second procès
comme tout le monde et a le droit à un
appel nicolas sarkozy
c'est normal ils l'utilisent et on sait
que dans ce genre d'affaires ça c'est
toujours vérifier jusqu'à présent les
juges sont plus cléments en appel parce
que les jugements sont souvent plus
juridique donc beaucoup plus beaucoup
moins à portée symbolique est beaucoup
plus sûr vraiment la qualification des
faits sur médiatique aussi l'émotion
médiatique elle sera là mais le débat en
appel il se porte souvent plus sur la
technicité de l'infraction et sait moins
c'est moins quelque chose de de
passionnel d'émotionnel on en vit en
deuxième thème de ce match messieurs
c'est cette une est ce dossier de
libération sur ses électeurs de gauche
qui assume de 10 aujourd'hui qu'en cas
de duel macron le pen au deuxième tour
ils ne voteront pas macron tout à fait
scandale
la démarche de libération dont vous avez
vu la une les témoignages de ceux qui ne
veulent plus de ce front républicain
avant d'en parler avec vous en plateau
on va accueillir dans ce match des idées
nicolas froment bonsoir vous êtes
sociologue co auteur de la guerre des
mots avec le journaliste céline derkaoui
et vous vous le dit clairement je crois
vous l'assumez en cas de duel macro le
pen vous ne voterez pas macron donc vous
assumerez le fait que potentiellement la
une le pen soit la présidente de la
france bonsoir oui effectivement je
l'assumé complètement je pense que je
l'assumé comme beaucoup de gens pas
seulement des électeurs de gauche mais
des gens à qui on a demandé à chaque
élection de faire ce genre de choix qui
n'en est pas réellement un le dernier en
date était donc en 2017 c'était le
fameux faire barrage à marine le pen en
votant pour emmanuel macron force est de
constater que ce barrage n'a pas
fonctionné ça n'a pas fonctionné parce
que finalement les idées et les actions
du gouvernement qu'on espérait stoppé en
empêchant marine le pen
devenir président de la république on y
assister avec emmanuel macron on a
assisté à la répression des mouvements
sociaux le mouvement des gilet jaune a
été tellement réprimer que c'est là un
qui était l'onu amnesty international
avec des arrestations préventives des
atteintes au droit à manifester
et puis on et assistent quotidiennement
dans la façon dont les migrants sont
traités sont traités par la police et
d'une façon générale toutes ces
personnes d'origine étrangère sont
traités par la police sans ce que les
choses se soient en passe de se résoudre
donc on peut tout à fait se demander
finalement pourquoi à quoi at-on fait
barrage exactement et surtout dans
quelle situation née et à partir de là
si tu aussi on est maintenant c est ce
qu'on voit à nouveau nous poser ce genre
de questions et c'est apparemment ce que
fait libé en proposant ce scénario
politique qui est absolument noir parce
qu'en réalité il nous demande de choisir
entre deux politiques qui sont plus ou
moins semblables même si évidemment dans
le style et l'apparence et se
distinguent fortement dans l'action sur
les populations sur les syndicalistes
sur les travailleurs sur les personnes
non blanches ou si les personnes
réfugiées
finalement les résultats se ressent
beaucoup nicolas framont avec cette
démarche c'est ce que vous n'avez pas
peur de braquer un certain nombre
d'électeurs qui se pose est
potentiellement la question de voter à
gauche et qui en voyant cette démarche
se dit non mais là je ne me reconnais
pas du tout dans ce qu'il est en train
de dire et du coup on n'iront pas voter
à gauche est ce que vous ne perdez pas
des électeurs à gauche en faisant cette
démarche
je ne sais même pas si je me revendique
ray de la gauche je pense que c'est un
terme qui ne serait ce que de tulle
françois hollande perturbe tout le monde
moi je me revendique eu de questions et
de débat qui intéresse les français à
savoir comment on améliore notre système
de santé
comment on donne de l'emploi à tout le
monde et comment on fait en sorte que
les riches n'est ce ne soit pas
accaparés par quelques personnes en plus
dans un contexte de la planète se
détruit voilà les sujets qui moi m'a
nîmes et c'est pour ça que vu que ce
sont ces fusées à qui m'anime
le faux choix qui est proposée par
libération et qui nous est proposé en
permanence pas ce choix là ne
m'intéresse pas et je pense qu'ils
n'intéressent pas beaucoup de gens
encore une fois des gens qui se
revendique de gauche ou pas vraiment
comme moi qui simplement est quelqu'un
qui sait d'améliorer la situation de la
france notamment sur le plan des
inégalités de l'accaparement des
richesses vous
compris que tout le monde enfin tout le
monde que beaucoup s'acharne sur sur
libération avec cette démarche vous avez
le sentiment que libération est en train
d'extrapoler un mini phénomène ou
libération a vraiment mis le doigt sur
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer dans cet électorat
je pense que d'une façon générale le
phénomène de l'abstentionnisme il est
peu étudiée il est peu commentés ou
uniquement sous un angle du scandale
politique
moi j'avais travaillé comme sociologue
sur l'abstention dès 2015 et je voyais
bien que c'était un sujet qui était
passionné parce que pour toute une
partie de la classe politique
l'abstention n'est pas une option
possible
c'est quelque chose qui dégrade la
république etc et effectivement quand on
s'abstient c'est qu'on se retire du jeu
on se retire du jeu politique qu'on nous
propose est particulièrement quand il
est bloqué moi je comprends que
libération ait voulu travailler sur ce
phénomène là qui est en étant
l'abstention c'est un phénomène qui est
grandissant dont on parle
une fois par soir électorale et dont on
ne parle pas tout le reste de l'année
alors que ce qu'on observe c'est que ce
phénomène il se développe à chaque
élection mais aussi à la présidentielle
parce que ce qui se passe c'est que
beaucoup de français ont le sentiment
que le débat politique est complètement
verrouillé que toutes les questions qui
les intéressent ne sont finalement pas
traité exactement comme ce qui va se
passer si jamais si jamais encore une
fois il faut on a un match
macron le pen le la seule chose que je
critiquerai sur cette une de libération
c'est cette façon aussi de faire comme
si les choses étaient joués on est en
il se passe énormément de choses pas
seulement liée au contexte sanitaire
mais également au contexte social et il
est un peu présentes d'imaginer que la
situation de 2017 se reproduire et mais
moi je comprends tout à fait que des
journalistes travaillent sur des
populations qui existent qui sont celles
des abstentionnistes intermittent ou
chronique c'est à dire des gens qui
pensent que à chaque élection faut quand
même se poser la question de sa
participation
restez avec nous nicolas fram on va
poursuivre la discussion plateau thierry
fabre d'abord sur cette idée que
nicolas froment et d'autres ne voient
trompa ne feront plus barrage à marine
le pen
alors ça a coûté beaucoup ont critiqué
la une de libé ça je comprends pas ce
que c'est
ils ont simplement traiter un vrai sujet
c'est à dire tous les je citerai un
sondage qui est sorti un sondage qui n'a
pas été publié sondage un peuple un
destin de harris interactive qu'il dit
ce week-end qu'on et d'engins dans un
mouchoir de poche
on entend avec un duel très le pen
macron donc c'est un précédent sondage
qui parlait de 52 48
là on est autour de 50 50 donc le
problème il est réel
ça signifie quoi ça veut dire que
effectivement beaucoup de gens notamment
issus de la gauche ne veulent plus faire
barrage et donc se disent le pen macron
même combat je ne voterai pas et
deuxième phénomène on sent une
banalisation accéléré de marine le pen
qui arrive qu'ils essayent comme ça de
percer sont peu son plafond de verre et
qui donc élargie de plus en plus son
électorat
un exemple marine le pen ne sais pas si
vous l'avez remarqué a publié une
tribune sur la dette publique mais j'ai
cru j'ai cru en collègue bruno le maire
mais non c'était incroyable c'est dans
l'opinion dans leur opinion est donc
très modérée il faudra rembourser la
dette donc elle essaye de lutter contre
7,7 réputation de femme politique qui ne
connaît pas ses dossiers qui est des
plus calmes et des propos qui faisaient
peur sur l'euro donc les deux phénomènes
se conjuguent
écoutez ma part elle et elle est d un
général et portela alors elle et moi ce
que je trouve extraordinaire ce qui le
met sur le le maquereau le pen même
combat et ce qui signifie que emmanuel
macron s'est forgé une image terrible
pendant ses premières années notamment
vis-à-vis de la gauche et alors on peut
créer on peut la déplorer cette image
que ce que je trouve qu'il ya un excès
quand tous les ce côté gauche on a
l'impression que côté social emmanuel
macron n'a rien fait alors qu'ici on
liste les mesures qui ont été mises en
place que ce soit côté écoles et même
que ce soit côté redistribution avec des
gilets jaunes
hier on fera le bilan à la fin du
quinquennat on pourrait se rendre compte
que la redistribution soumah kron a été
importante
contraint et forcé mais enfin il a
augmenté les minima sociaux la prime
d'activité la taxe d'habitation a été
supprimé mais simplement son image dans
le kiss et christ
elle est catastrophique parce qu'elle
est cette image de président des riches
et donc s'étant créés pour la gauche ce
n'est que le président des riches et
toute mesure ce soir au lycée rossi
d'ailleurs plus ça je te mets en matière
économique et sociale
c'est ce qui ressort est effectivement
même s'il a fait un certain nombre de
choses
elles n'apparaissent absolument pas aux
yeux de l'électorat de gauche tient à
voter pour lui oui de prime abord je
suis toujours assez circonspect quand on
met un signe égal entre les pratiques
politiques et le programme politique d'
emmanuel macron et de marine le pen si
on se reporte simplement au programme de
2010 est alors qu'on pense que c'est
bien ou que c'est mal et avait quand
même des deux sacrée différence avec ce
que fait emmanuel macron je pense à un
référendum sur la peine de mort qui a
été dans le dans le programme de marine
le pen
je pense à un référendum sur la sortie
de l'union européenne qui a été dans le
programme de marine le pen
je pense à une présomption de légitime
défense pour les policiers puisque
nicolas fram on parlait de violences
policières
on peut peut-être pas à mettre un signe
égal entre ce que fait manuel macron est
ce que préconisait marine le pen mais je
pense à l'expulsion d'un certain nombre
de fichiers ce qui figurait dans le dans
le programme de marine le pen
les programmes ne sont pas semblables on
voit cela étant ce qui affleure dans ce
débat et c'est quand même et c'est
intéressant
moi en tout cas c'est comme ça que je le
comprends c'est une demande une demande
très vive d'un vrai débat politique aux
prochaines élections et qu'ils ne soient
pas cadenassé par ce par cette présence
de marine le pen et qui oblige à
finalement se déclarer pour au contre et
ne pas parler d'économie de social de
sécurité de mode de vie finalement ne
pas avoir en débat
voilà une vraie idéologie et la
lassitude s'était d'as et l angle de
libération très intéressant moi aussi
j'ai été assez consterné par les
réactions face à ce dossier
eux ils ont travaillé sur la lassitude
du peuple de gauche
des sympathisants de la gauche et c'est
vrai que cette lassitude
elles existent parce que la dernière
fois c'est ses sympathisants ainsi en
tout cas ceux qui n'ont voté ni macro ni
marine le pen avait l'impression au
deuxième tour de ne pas avoir un vrai
choix politique
donc il ya je comprends le jeu comprend
le discours de quelqu'un comme nicolas
framont qui se situe à priori dans cet
espace là parce qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas d'intérêt aujourd'hui à dire je vais
faire barrage à marine le pen parce que
c'est accepter est placé comme un fait
acter que y aura pas d'élection en 2022
que emmanuel macron et marine le pen
seront qualifiés kg faudra revoter pour
emmanuel macron une nouvelle fois quand
on vient de cet espace politique l'a
donc à gauche aujourd'hui ne serait ce
que par intérêt politique
et c'est normal c'est aussi ça la
compétition électorale il ya aucun
intérêt à clamer haut et fort qu'on va
revoter une nouvelle fois emmanuel
macron encore une fois on verra ce que
vous feront les personnes au soir du
premier tour
au sein de la france un soumise par
exemple rappelez-vous en 2017 et jean
luc mélenchon avait tenu ligne je ne dis
pas pour qui je vote je ne me prononce
pas hanter manuel macron et marine le
pen en réalité quelques semaines après
élection je pense à quelqu'un comme
alexis corbière qui est devenu député
avait dit elle avait dit que lui à titre
personnel avait voté emmanuel macron
donc il y a les consignes de vote
officiel des états majors politiques
pour des raisons politiques
et il ya ce que feront les gens en leur
âme et conscience le jour de l'élection
nicolet franoux voulait conclure en
quelques secondes
oui je pense que les questions qu'on
doit se poser c'est effectivement et ce
qu'un débat politique va avoir lieu en
2022 et le débat politique il est
actuellement suspendu en france depuis
quelques années maintenant avec
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron qui est
un gouvernement très vertical voire
autoritaire et donc le débat il n'a pas
lieu il ya de fausses instance de débat
qui sont créés et je pense au grand
débat national qui avait été fait il ya
deux ans et dont on n'a plus jamais
entendu parler je pense à la convention
climat qui après avoir donné sa mauvaise
note n'a juste plus voix au chapitre
donc il ya des faux instance de débat
mais il n'y a pas il n'y a plus de vrai
débat politique en france il n'y a plus
moyen en tant que citoyens d'exprimer
ses positions politiques notamment par
rapport aux grands sujets sur lequel
marine le pen et emmanuel macron sont de
plus en plus d'accord comme vous l'avez
dit c'est à dire les sujets économiques
et sociaux les sujets liés à la
redistribution des richesses à la
récompense du travail et à la façon dont
on peut vivre libre et souverain
ces sujets là si on nous dit dès
maintenant qu'ils n'apparaissent pas en
2022 effectivement beaucoup de gens vont
seront se désintéresser de cette
élection et tenter de faire les choses
autrement ils n'auront pas tort et on a
bien compris le message merci infiniment
nicolas framont d'avoir participé à ce
le match des idées troisième thème le
déplacement des manuels macro à stains
ce matin en seine saint denis sur le
thème de l'égalité des chances et de
l'emploi des jeunes il inaugurait un
contenu se baptiser industries est un
site créé par la fondation total qui
permet à des jeunes de se former aux
métiers de l'industrie gratuitement sans
condition de diplôme le chef de l'état a
voulu saluer l'engagement des
entreprises en faveur des jeunes et
faire un point sur le plan un jeune une
solution écouter mais n'y a pas de
fatalité
notre pays traverse une crise très dure
qui est lié à cette crise sanitaire et à
ses conséquences économiques et sociales
malgré tout l'année 2020 parce qu'on
sait mobiliser parce que l'état a mis en
place des dispositifs parce que les
entreprises étaient là on a battu le
record de l'apprentissage dans notre
pays
cinq cent mille cinq cent mille jeunes
en apprentissage ya pas de fatalité il
ya juste des solutions à trouver
moi je n'ai pas à dire quel sera
l'avenir de nos jeunes mais on a
collectivement entreprises associations
gouvernement a essayé de leur offrir la
possibilité ou de se former ou d'accéder
à une première expérience qui va ensuite
l'ordre donné la force et les moyens de
bâtir leur propre leur propre carrière à
leur propre vie
leur thierry fabre bravo l'état bravo
les entreprises c'est un peu ça le
message en substance
l'autocongratulation alors c'est normal
qu'ils viennent un petit peu secoué les
entreprises pour justement les inciter à
prendre des jeunes notamment en stage en
ce moment parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est là la grande galère avec la crise
du coc vide mais cette initiative en
fait ça envoie un peu à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur ce que fait emmanuel
macron c'est à dire que c'est pas
peut-être pas fondamental à l'échelle de
son bilan mais ce qu'il a fait sur
l'apprentissage c'est quand même une
mesure sociale qu'on peut même
l'estampillé de gauche si on veut pas
dire que ce système fonctionnait très
mal depuis des années ont dit on vous en
veut autant de l'apprenti qu'en
allemagne où c'est un vrai passeport
pour l'emploi
ça ne fonctionnait pas il la réforme et
il a sorti ce système de régie année
nicolas froment avec nous alors oui mais
c'est à dire et j'espère qu'ils nous
écoutent et le nom il est là et il l'a
confié plus tôt aux branches
professionnelles
il a déverrouillé ce qui fait que le
nombre d'apprentis a explosé avant le
col vide
hélas malgré le coc vie d'alors et des
aides financières de l'état assez
confortable on est à peu près au même
niveau record donc les mesures sociales
macron il en a fait et concernant les
jeunes c'est plutôt réussi et il
comprend qu'il aille faire la publicité
de ce dispositif sur les jeunes l'autre
point à des risques au vide où il n'a
pas du tout réussi en revanche c'est les
yeux les jeunes de la fac
non là c'était les images de ces
catastrophes noces est catastrophique
c'est intéressant de mettre les deux en
parallèle les les jeunes et notamment
les peu qualifiés il ya quand même des
choses côté état et quand on voit le
temps de réaction par rapport à la
détresse des étudiants là ils n'ont pas
vu venir le problème mais c'est quand
même
voilà où on fera le bilan macron en
temps venu c'est pas du tout le moment
puisqu'on ne parle que la crise du coc
vide est effectivement d'aller mesure de
social de maquereaux il ya notamment ces
mesures formation où il a détricoté des
systèmes
c'est compliqué un peu technique donc
c'est que ce n'était pas simple sur lui
mais simplement on peut quand même lui
dire concrètement il il a fait le boulot
pour déverrouiller et heureusement
qu'aujourd'hui notre système
d'apprentissage fonctionne pas mal parce
qu'évidemment ça aurait été encore pire
pour nos jeunes notamment les peu
qualifiés
vous êtes d'accord et tienne gérard pas
tout à fait parce que moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est quand même une grande
disproportion entre ce qui a été annoncé
concrètement si j'ai bien lu un plan à
30 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui le plan sur le mentorat et
l'état de la situation qui pour les
jeunes est un désastre
il ya sept points de plus de chômage
chez les jeunes cette année c'est pas de
la faute des manuels macron a c'est de
la faute du coc vide il n'y a aucun
souci
seulement tout le tout la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron sur le chômage et sur le
chômage des jeunes se fondait sur ce qui
a été appelé de façon un peu critique au
début du quinquennat mais qui
correspondent à quelque chose
le ruissellement c'est à dire on va
favoriser l'investissement on va faire
on va déployer on va libérer les
énergies et les entreprises vont
embaucher à foison et les jeunes parmi
les autres en profiteront profiteront de
cela ce qui se passe c'est que cette
grande stratégie globale elle est
aujourd'hui complètement par terre parce
que le coc vide l'a mis par terre parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'activités pour les
jeunes c'est très difficile depuis un an
et le plan d'aujourd'hui
alors c'est bien de faire des
déplacements c'est pas la question mais
il est pas y correspond pas à l'ampleur
de la situation
30 millions d'euros ça ne suffit
absolument pas pour répondre aux
difficultés chez un chômage des jeunes a
plus de 25% dit on selon les chiffres
provisoires de l'insee c'est quand même
extrêmement préoccupante et dont il
faudra d'autres plans sans doute quelque
chose de beaucoup plus ambitieux avec
beaucoup plus d'argent pour pour régler
la wii et que les jeunes vraiment ajoute
je trouve sévère parce que là il faut
pas en rester à l'annoncé d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas 30 millions mais c'est
plusieurs milliards qui sont dans le
plan de relance pour la formation et
donc ses îles et non quand même côté
formation il ya eu ce que vous appelez
la stratégie du ruissellement qui est
l'attractivité la libre la
flexibilisation du marché du travail
et donc on fait tout pour le pro pour
les peler les chalands de reprise et
pour le business mais de l'autre côté il
ya eu des réformes qui ont été faites
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et
quelques milliards à rien un paquet de
milliards sur les plans de formation et
notamment se plante dans le plan de
relance il ya à peu près un tiers qui
est réservé à la formation et à l'emploi
dont ce côté là le l'état quand même
fait le job pour dire j'ai investi alors
c'est encore pas suffisant et peut-être
et surtout à l'échelle de la crise on va
se rendre compte qu'il faut en rajouter
mais on peut pas simplement qualifié
macron de libéral et se dire ça se
passera le marché va tout régler
il a été libérale mais il a aussi
détricoter des dispositifs publics et
mis un paquet d'argent public dans ce
domaine pour les jeunes et puis pour les
autres si puisque la formation
professionnelle à a reçu pas mal de
deniers de l'état sur l'information
effectivement des choses ont été
annoncées
j'attends de voir ce que ça va donner
réellement concrètement quand il faudra
mettre les mesures en place et j'ai une
mesure en tête qui a été à mon avis très
décevante alors ça recours beaucoup plus
largement que le chômage des jeunes
je pense à la grande promesse sur les
démissions le fait qu' on pourra
désormais démissionné de son travail et
être indemnisées comme quelqu'un au
chômage qui a été licencié et c'était ça
la flexisécurité d' emmanuel macron l'
équilibre entre le libéralisme et la
protection au final ce plan il a été
décrite détricoter totalement on a gardé
le libéralisme économique et la sécurité
pour les gens qui démissionne bah en
fait on a dit qu' il faudra passer par
une commission qui verra si le plan
c'est roland si elle aurait compliqué a
lancé son entreprise par exemple est
viable et sinon on n'aura pas le droit
de toucher l'allocation cheuvreux ce
point là je vous donne raison c'est à
dire que c'est effectivement c'est un
point une promesse de campagne qui était
un peu beaucoup trop enfin irréaliste
d'ailleurs ils sont rendus compte qu'au
moment où il fallait sortie internet
jacques il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
gens qui se disaient avec un je vais je
vais me reconvertir et du coup ils ont
serré totalement les critères et
effectivement ça c'était une mauvaise
une fausse promesse
iai il a fait un certain nombre de
choses mais en l'occurrence la
flexisécurité à la macro là elle n'a pas
fonctionné vous avez raison et sur
l'argent mis quand même par l'état
oui non mais le plan de relance il
existe il est réel il est conséquent moi
je demande à voir
en dernier recours parce que il ya
toujours un décalage le dossier de la
démission de la wii de la démission le
montre mais il y en a d'autres comme ça
il ya toujours un décalage entre
l'annoncent vague lors d'un discours
présidentiel l'allocation globale des
milliards est ce qu'on va faire sur le
terrain concrètement en réalité le
dossier de la formation c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est pas du tout
facile de trouver des formations qui
correspondent à ce que veulent faire les
gens ça tous les gens de pôle emploi
vous l'expliquer c'est à dire qu' il ya
des métiers où il ya de l'offre il ya
énormément d'offres
il n'y a pas assez de gens qui quittent
qui travaillent mais les gens ça ne les
intéresse pas et les jeunes notamment de
travailler dans ces branches a donc le
ce sera comme dit d'ailleurs l'entourage
des manuels macron dans la politique des
derniers kilomètres c'est à dire comment
au final on fait pour que cette mesure
elle profite réellement aux gens que je
serais à même de juger si oui ou non ce
a tenu ses promesses et ce sera la
dernière idée de ce match de ce match
merci beaucoup à tous les deux dit avoir
participé c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouvent demain à 18 heures et à
22h30 dans un instant auditions
publiques l'invité ce soir et franck
riester ministre délégué chargé du
commerce extérieur et de l'attractivité
et puis demain vous retrouvez bonjour
chez vous oriane mancini recevra
notamment françois xavier bellamy
eurodéputés lr je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat
pour